[Musique]
le président de la république a clôturé
sa visite à la réunion par un pique
nique sur le site de grande anse un
moment d'échangé convivial le président
rencontrer les exposants du prochain
salon international de l'agriculture
dont les productions sont régulièrement
récompensées pour leur excellence il a
échangé sur les propriétés de certaines
plantes locales et goûter à quelques
saveurs ping pour nous c'est une
promotion s'est aussi fait découvrir
aussi le savoir-faire de la réunion et
aussi ce qu'on peut faire avec les
produits locaux il ya beaucoup de temps
this it et quand même je veux dire c'est
des produits conquis qui qui qui qui
sont ancrées de notre tradition
tradition et fait découvrir sa cccc que
tu connais un très grand honneur pour
présenter nos produits montré compétent
indolence d'eau dans notre domaine mais
également parlé des bondé de nos
réussites
une séquence importante pour la
collectivité départementale chef de file
en matière agricole
le président était au contact des
agriculteurs il y a eu des échanges des
discussions chacun pu présenter ces
problèmes et le président ben ali je
crois qu'il a maintenant pleinement
conscience des enjeux liés à
l'agriculture réunionnaise en termes de
production de transformation et aussi de
commercialisation nous ce que l'on veut
c'est les produits p dans les assiettes
des réunionnaises et des réunionnais on
veut montrer au président le meilleur de
la culture réunionnaise mais aussi ses
difficultés parce qu'il ya des
difficultés faut pas le nier
nous sommes ici face à par exemple des
attaques pourra sur les manques sur les
fruits ben l'on n'a signalé çà au
président pour que l'état accompagne les
agriculteurs comme le fait le
département avant de partir le président
de la république a tenu à remercier le
département en écrivant dans le livre
d'or de la collectivité
les stars
[Musique]